Why not methylated B vitamins for cancer?
Okay, so methyl groups are essential for life.
We need methyl groups.
So a methyl group is a carbon with three hydrogens, and it can bind to, you could use it to bind
to different nutrients, to get them exogenously, you also get methyl groups through your foods.
So most people that are eating good diets are getting plenty of methyl groups, but taking
exogenous methyl groups, taking exogenous methyl groups in B vitamins, you're taking methyl
cobalamine, which is methyl B12 for methyl tetrahedral folate, which is a methyl methyl
folate.
Now most natural doctors will say, that's the best type of folate, that's the best type of
B12.
Well, maybe, maybe not.
Well, certainly maybe not, if you have cancer.
The reason is that what are the major things that methyl groups do is they silence genes,
so they turn off genes, which you need to have genes turned off at different times.
However, one of your greatest way to kill cancer, if you have cancer, is through a pathway
called your intrinsic, meaning inside the cell, capsaic pathway, or intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So the intrinsic apoptotic pathway is stimulated by, when a cancer cell is going through rapid
replication, it stimulates what are called your tumor suppressor genes.
Everybody has them.
You have lots of different tumor suppressor gene families.
The bronca gene is probably the most well known by lay people.
So the bronca genes are a tumor suppressor gene that turns out in breast cancer and can
help kill the breast cancer, so you never know you even have breast cancer, because it's
dead before it gets to a size of you ever discovering that.
Now if you take a bunch of methyl groups, you can turn those genes off, so you can hinder
your body's ability to kill cancer.
So my rule is, if you have cancer, you're not taking methyl groups, take other forms of
B12 and other forms of folate.